so a few weeks ago I told you about the
Trump administration giving a huge
contract for n95 masks to a company with
no employees whose parent company
recently filed for bankruptcy and we
have another one of these stories we've
now learned about the Trump
administration giving a contract worth
anywhere from three hundred and fifty
four million potentially up to eight
hundred and twelve million dollars to a
tiny Virginia company that has only been
around since January it's been four
months and everything about this stinks
the company is called flow with a pH pH
L o W was created in January brand-new
company the CEO is dr. Eric Edwards will
talk about him in a minute he told The
Associated Press that Flo's mission is
to make the American drug supply chain
less reliant on other countries that's
something Trump's been talking about a
lot bringing our supply chains home in
the context of coronavirus we don't know
much about the company since it's only
been around for four months but we do
know a little something about their CEO
because dr. Eric Edwards previously had
a company with his twin brother called K
Leo they increased the price of an
opioid antidote by six hundred percent
over three years at a cost to taxpayers
of a hundred and forty two million
dollars they tried to get some positive
PR by donating a bunch of doses to first
responders and then we heard from
several law enforcement agencies that
the doses they got from this company k
leo were sometimes as little as four
months from expiring nice nice right
they also charged forty five hundred
dollars for their rival to the EpiPen
which was really more of an insurance
scam it was the idea was get insurance
companies paying them these outrageous
reimbursements for their competitor to
the EpiPen and of course what that leads
to is that people's insurance premiums
end up having to go up the idea that hey
the insurance company is paying so we
don't have to worry about it well then
everybody's premiums go up to account
for what they expect to be paying for
that and other medications of course
nothing illegal as far as we know this
is unfortunately this type of type of
stuff that's terrifically legal under
system so what's the connection why is
this company getting such a great deal
from the Trump administration well what
we know so far is that Trump's wacky
economic adviser Peter Navarro admitted
he bonded with a board member of this
company flow over get this skepticism
about China seems like China's
skepticism can be very very profitable
for this for people associated with this
administration so what exactly is this
company going to be doing for their
three hundred and fifty-four million
dollars they aim to manufacture some of
the raw ingredients for drugs in the
United States that would be needed to
treat coronavirus patients we don't
exactly know what that means the
contract is initially for three hundred
and fifty four million dollars over four
years it could be extended to a ten-year
deal for eight hundred and twelve
million dollars this would be one of the
largest amounts of money ever awarded to
a company in this type of arrangement
now you may not be surprised that the
flow website has a lot of the same sort
of America first style rhetoric and
language that Trump often bandies about
so in a week we might hear about some
further connection to the Trump family
wouldn't be surprising it'll barely get
attention it'll be another one of these
crony moves that Donald Trump promised
to stop this is a classic cash grab and
you see this a lot in more corrupt
countries or countries that are more
corrupt in this particular way the u.s.
is corrupted in sort of different ways
often you have a crisis and all sorts of
brand-new companies will be set up very
few employees very few questions about
whether they really do anything and they
get these massive lucrative contracts
this specific case with this company
flow it may or may not be an out-and-out
scam most likely the company is going to
do something but there could be shell
companies involved these are often
techniques to hide foreign interests or
other nefarious interests you can use
these to funnel money around and in a
lot of different ways it's the type of
stuffed Trump loves and in the end it's
our tax money it's our tax money during
times of crisis that gets funneled to
people that are making so much money
while 25% of the workforce has lost
their jobs this is what 63 million
people voted for either knowingly or
unknowingly I was reminded when I was
researching this story about the
whitefish fiasco
during the puerto rican hurricane
recovery although to call it a recovery
is probably probably a bit of an
exaggeration there was this company
whitefish energy based in montana two
full-time employees they concocted an
online presence with a hundred online
positive reviews they did it all within
72 hours of getting a 300 million dollar
contract from the Trump administration
the Trump interior secretary at the time
Ryan's Enki happened to be from the same
town as this company people associated
with the company happened to be big
investors big investors talk about a
Freudian slip donors to Donald Trump it
was a total swamp job and eventually
Puerto Rico canceled the contract and
now we are indeed seeing much of the
same around coronavirus a lot of money
being made with coronavirus that's for
sure if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink it's blink Isleta consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka
blink East has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25% off a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash Pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video